hey everyone
i'm jill biden's husband
but the truth is she's the strongest
person i know she's a backbone like a
ramrod
that's the kind of first lady lady lady
lady this jill biden will be
god love you
all right people it's june 2nd 2022 i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message we are live streaming on
rumble youtube and blaze tv and tonight
is the big night i am in orlando with
florida governor ron desantis it is sold
out about a thousand people it is going
to be jam-packed i'm hearing some
protesters are going to be there because
not everybody likes the governor and
believe it or not not everybody likes
little old me so what we are doing today
believe it or not i'm about to blow the
magic of the internet for you uh this is
a pre-tape i'm actually taping this
yesterday because i'm in a car right now
enroute to orlando however we're
bringing you
an a-plus all-star show because you know
each day i send my guys clips throughout
the day that we try to work into the
show and fit into the narrative that
we're trying to do on any given day but
we always have all these other clips
that we can't quite get to or this is
two bananas if we're trying to do
something serious or this is too serious
if we're trying to do something crazy so
this is just a general insanity recap
just a whole bunch of general lunacy and
ridiculous nonsense that we could not
get to over the last week or so there is
a lot of it and let's
get
right to it let me just talk to you
about real estate agents i trust real
quick you know buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent generally speaking our homes
are our biggest investment and that's a
lot of responsibility so you need an
agent who takes that seriously that's
why i recommend real estate agents i
trust founded by my good buddy glenn
beck they work with only the best agents
in every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join the team and here's a big
one they only work with full-time pros
no part-time or experienced agents their
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this very audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go including orlando florida the
process is simple just go to
realestateagentsidetrust.com
and provide them with some basic info
and the team will contact you to make an
intro to a preferred agent in your town
and now back to me okay so here we go
this is gonna be a half hour
of general lunacy here is whoopi
goldberg on the view the abortion right
the battle is starting to blur the lines
between church and state the archbishop
of san francisco
is calling for speaker nancy pelosi to
be denied receiving communion because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for president
biden to be denied sacrament this is not
your job dude
that is not you can't that is not up to
you to make that decision
you know what is the saying it's kind of
amazing
uh
but
you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh sinners
it's the for the for sinners it's the
reward of saints but the bread of
sinners how dare you
how dare you oh whoopee whoopy whatever
happened to ghost whoopi whatever
happened to the whoopee of old the
whoopee who was the laughing hyena in
lion king or some of the other stuff
that whoopi did a long time ago she's
just she's just become one of these
shrieking people uh whoopi i'm pretty
sure it is his job to decide who
can do communion that that is his job it
ain't your job you're entitled to your
opinion on it um but if he is saying hey
as the bishop here in san francisco and
this is her district and she's doing
things that are completely against our
belief system well then as a religion as
a set of beliefs as an ideology they are
allowed to include certain people in
those rituals or not include certain
people in those rituals and by the way i
would say that about any religion any
set of beliefs and any people that want
to believe in it or participate it or
not i would not be forcing a mosque
let's say to do a gay marriage
so we have all sorts of hypocrites right
ilhan omar goes to a mosque somewhere in
minnesota and she pretends she's this
big lgbt ally her mosque obviously does
not do gay weddings i'm pretty sure
there's no mosques in america that do
gay weddings and that's completely up to
them it's a religion they don't have to
bow to me or to secular wishes
but these people if there is a hypocrite
here but it's you whoopi i mean it's you
not understanding what the very purpose
of these uh religious
rights and religious practices are so
that was just one thing related to
whoopi and nancy pelosi the other big
story about nancy pelosi uh this week
her husband
he's a drunk so here we go from the
post-millennial it has come to light
that nancy pelosi's husband paul was
behind the wheel when his brother died
in a car accident as a teenager okay i'm
reading that a little glibly that was a
while back on saturday night nancy
pelosi's husband paul was arrested for
drunk driving shortly after crashing his
porsche into a jeep on a california
freeway it has been since revealed that
this was not mr pelosi's first time
being behind the wheel during an
accident
at 16 years old he was driving with his
brother david 19 in the passenger seat
when he lost control of the vehicle and
flipped it into the embankment mr pelosi
survived but his brother david was
killed so obviously i'm not making light
of his brother being killed the fact
that nancy pelosi's husband uh is being
arrested for dui and is probably an
alcoholic would explain a lot about her
i mean i'm pretty sure she's an
alcoholic but the denture's falling out
and eaten the ice cream while she has
the rest of us locked in and all of that
stuff this is the type of story that you
probably did not hear about because she
is a democrat and when democrats either
get caught doing drugs or in orgies or
you know driving drunk et cetera et
cetera that skates under the radar when
republicans do it or
republicans are accused of doing it
let's say uh these things absolutely
blow up but
more importantly than any of that this
is june and what is june people it is l
g b t
q
i plus l m n o p month okay and that
means you have to put up a flag it once
was the rainbow flag people enjoyed the
rainbow you see a rainbow oh what's on
the other side of the rainbow what's at
the end of the rainbow it's a pot of
gold a little leprechaun very nice now
it's complete insanity okay now it's
lesbians with penises it's uh what else
do they got they got they got the whole
thing out there
uh anyway it is lgbt pride month and
what does disney plus have for us well
they've got a new drag queen show for
kids
hello
and welcome to the disney plus this is
me pride celebration spectacular i'm
nina west and i'm here to guide you
through a magical musical and
meaningful celebration of the lgbtq plus
community glsen's mission is to create
safe and inclusive schools for lgbtq
plus students in grades k-12 and disney
plus is so proud to support this
wonderful organization for more
information visit www.glsen.org
[Music]
forward slash pride phoenix i want to
thank you for having the barf bag next
to me while we were playing that clip i
i've just had it with these people like
what does that have to do with children
it has nothing to do with children if
you wish
to dress up
as an adult as any gender wear a
ridiculous wig put on a lot of lipstick
blah blah blah do whatever the hell you
want but this should have nothing to do
with children and also this has nothing
to do with gay people or lesbians this
trans thing the lg and even the bee
the confused bees they have nothing to
do with the tea thing and the fact that
disney plus this giant corporate
conglomerate uh is pushing this stuff on
children i cancelled disney plus i
recommend you cancel
disney plus and if you're showing that
to your kids do you think that those
people those drag queens there that
those are happy highly functioning
people who are going to do really well
in society and build lasting families
and be productive members of the
community like it is possible i suppose
at some level right so i don't mean it
about those two uh
characters whatever they are
specifically uh but generally speaking
is this what you want to push on
children this is what you want to push
on six seven-year-olds
what do you think what do you think but
the thing is this thing has leaked into
everything and as i promised this show
is about the endless insanity that is
everywhere here is biden education
secretary miguel angel cardona defending
uh dudes with penises in women's sports
do you believe it's fair or not for
biological boys
to compete against girls in sports it's
a simple question
i believe all students should have
access to uh sport
so you do you do support biological boys
competing against girls in sports
i believe i answered the question no you
haven't just it's a simple question just
answer the question you either the
administration either supports it or you
don't you're saying do i believe
transgender uh girls should have access
to sports yes i do complete clown show
these people are just ridiculous clowns
and i keep saying they don't deserve
your attention they deserve your
complete mockery and that's it there are
differences between boys and girls
that's how it is okay
generally speaking guys are bigger guys
are stronger the worst nba player the
worst guy in the nba there is a guy on
some nba team i don't watch the nba
anymore because it's gone woke there is
a guy somewhere on the nba who is the
12th man on the worst team in the league
averaging probably one point a game if
that he would be the mvp of the wnba
that does not mean that women cannot
love basketball and be quite good at
basketball when i was in high school i
went to the same high school as sue bird
sue bird was a multiple wnba uh mvp i
was a couple years older than her but i
played with her on the court
in the local park a couple times she was
running circles around guys that's
pretty great but generally speaking the
best wnba player would would never even
make it to the nba i am 45 with a torn
acl and i'm going to put on a dress and
i'm going to be in the wnba wasn't there
a movie about what was that movie jumana
jumana what was it come on connor you're
the only one that gets my references
around here lately jumana juwanna play
me what was it called the movie about
the the guy who became a wnba player he
was a washout joanna play me jumanji
mama come on
joanna man okay thank you there was a
moo thank you very much jesus anyway
these people are absolutely ridiculous
and we can make fun of it but then
there's this other part of it that
actually is very serious so here's the
education secretary basically saying
that teachers rights come before
parental rights do you believe that
school districts
should keep a child's involvement and
gender transition a secret from their
parents
sir i
i would love to answer questions on the
budget which is why i'm here and i i
think what what i'm saying secretary
these are policies that your
administration stands by you're asking
me to fund your budget and these are
policies that you stand for
it's completely relevant to why you're
here today it's a simple question and
answer the question do you think the
schools should keep it a secret from
their parents
if their children are involved in gender
transition parents listen parents and
schools must work together to support
students and i do strongly support and
if you look through the work that we've
uh supported and and our policies and
our practices we want parents should
schools ever keep that a secret from
parents
excuse me
should schools ever keep it a secret
from parents
if their children are involved in gender
transition school should only be a
secret from parents
schools should be partnering with
parents in communication and there are
times where schools
are
working and supporting students on
issues that are very sensitive
it's vile it's disgusting and you must
get your children out of
public schools to the best of your
ability and i know it is not easy for
everybody and not everyone can afford a
private school or a charter school this
is why we should be funding students
instead of systems but if you think that
guy and the rest of these crazy woke
activists have your kid's best interest
in mind and if you want your second
grade daughter to be talking to a male
or female teacher about straight or gay
sex or about gender transitioning or the
rest of it man you're like as a parent
to be i honestly i cannot even imagine i
cannot even imagine where your head
could be at if you think that's okay but
they are pushing this this is the policy
of the administration which is why that
guy comes off as such a waffling fool he
can't
answer anything honest honestly because
he knows that the honest answer is yes
of course he is for the state having
more power over the children the state
being able to privately talk to kids
about all of this gender stuff and not
report it to the parents we've got some
info here from rebel news on what the
administration is doing the biden
administration announced in may that k
through 12 schools must allow boys into
girls bathrooms in order to qualify for
federal funds used to pay for school
lunches the move which was made by the
u.s department of agriculture's food and
nutrition service was made based on the
interpretation of the prohibition on
discrimination based on sex as detailed
in title ix of the education amendments
of 1972 as well as the food and
nutrition act of 2008. so you got it
that's what they'll do that's what the
policy of this administration is the
policy flatly is we're going to put boys
and girls bathrooms we're going to put
girls in boys bathrooms we're going to
be able to hide information from you as
parents we're going to talk to them
about all this gender identity nonsense
and it is just not going to stop this so
this is exactly where i would say to my
my good liberal friends hey you guys
voted for this you guys thought that
biden was not you know like bernie in
the lunatics but here he is so where
where are you right now are you speaking
up about it are you going to vote for
this guy again do you have any regrets
over the last couple years but it's not
just gender it's not just gender that
they're doing all of this stuff with of
course it's race right race is the main
one that's the big that's the biggie uh
and joe biden has become a complete race
huckster listen to this one
because we've seen all too often
public trust is frayed and broken
and that undermines public safety
the families here today
and across the country have had to ask
why this nation why so many black
americans wake up knowing they could
lose their life and of course just
living their lives today
simply jogging shopping sleeping at home
whether they made headlines or not lost
souls gone too soon
what a vile disgusting human being he
really is and again i get it he's just
reading [ __ ] that they handed him and he
doesn't even know what he's saying and
everything else black people are being
shot while jogging or just laying at
home what are you talking about now
unless you mean in chicago where it is
black people shooting black people over
50 uh people shot last weekend i think
about eight killed but we don't talk
about that right that was more people
shot in chicago last weekend that
happened in uvalde last week but that's
not exactly what he's referring to but
this he wants a certain set of people to
think they're coming for you and we're
the only ones that can save you it's
just
disgusting and by the way regardless of
whether you're black or white or gay or
straight or the rest of it if you're a
law by abiding citizen if you go out
there and act responsib responsibly in
the world most likely you're going to be
okay and probably some good things are
going to happen to you but again this is
not just biden and it's not just the
administration it's the entire democrat
machine so let's jump back to gender and
let's go over to what was once my home
state i'm embarrassed to say it was
here's governor kathy sieward new
yorkers you can now choose x as your
gender marker on your driver's license
every person deserves to have an
identity document that reflects who they
are this is a historic change in our
fight to make new york a more inclusive
and just state for all what a ridiculous
buffoon kathy is she is just horrible
remember nobody voted for her this is a
woman who came in after they got rid of
andrew cuomo x is not a gender okay
usually you put x on things because i'm
not that am xing it out i'm crossing it
out or x
it just means nothing right x is not a
gender so on your driver's license you
could just put x and just because you
put x doesn't mean you're not a man or a
woman you still are a man or a woman
god you people are terrible but there's
more here's new york city this is an
incredible tweet this is from noah
pollock he found this one this is wild
from the new york city subway friend who
lives in manhattan sends pic of this
subway ad courtesy of the new york city
department of health heroin addiction
it's empowering don't be ashamed you are
using be empowered that you are using
safely
this is the nonsense
this is the complete and utter nonsense
that they are now putting on the subway
too the ad in no way condemns people who
are using heroin or makes it seem to
young people perhaps that using heroin
is bad it basically don't be ashamed of
using heroin you know kind of use it
more responsibly be cool about your
heroin usage you know what i mean and
your meth usage and all that stuff you
know let's get you on some opioids too
you want some crack god these people are
horrible so you will
i don't know what that i don't know
exactly what that was
um that was like a cool guy being like
yo you want to buy some drugs man um
these but so okay so they want to
confuse you about your gender gender
they want to make everyone think
everyone's racist they want you on
heroin
but it couldn't denews then there was
the big world economic the wef the world
economic forum event last week
here is video of alibaba group president
j michael evans and uh he's gonna hunt
you people down we're developing
through technology an ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform
so
individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on
hey you want an individual carbon
footprint tracker so i can see what
you're eating and how your health is how
was that that was that same drug dealer
guy because it's the same thing you get
my point these people want to track you
and confuse you about your gender and
make you think you're racist and get you
hooked on heroin and lock you in the
metaverse with something attached to
your genitals and you ain't ever gonna
leave but there's more they also want to
control what you're gonna say here's
video of australian e-safety
commissioner julie in inman grant
talking about what they're gonna have to
do related to free speech because you
people keep saying what you're thinking
we are finding ourselves in a place um
where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere and everything
feels binary when it doesn't need to be
so i think we're going to have to think
about a recalibration of a whole range
of human rights that are playing out
online you know from freedom of speech
to the freedom to
you know to be free from online violence
or the right of data protection to the
right to child dignity guys these are
the elites and you can't be making fun
of them they're better than you and
while they're eating steak you will eat
bugs don't you understand while they fly
private you will be masked on a plane
they're better and stop saying all that
mean stuff about them
uh this is pretty beautiful uh this is
uh a journalist an australian journalist
uh avi yemeni uh who went up to new york
times deputy manager editor rebecca
blumenstein at the world economic forum
she didn't want anything to do with it
but he had a microphone and he's a guy
rebecca how are you doing from new york
times can i ask you a quick question avi
from rebel news how is the public meant
to believe that the new york times is
here to actually ask the tough questions
when you're here as an invited guest
[Applause]
how are people meant to rely on the
mainstream media
if you wouldn't mind we're just having
just if you could give us you know thank
you
you don't want to explain to people why
we should trust the mainstream media
no of course no comment there we go so
that's the point here is in davos you
have the mainstream media that i'm not
here to report the truth they are here
as part of the event invited guests with
a white name tags
avi yemeni over at rebel news great work
brother i mean that's what it's all
about they invite the media to report on
what they're doing and then you wonder
why they get glowing coverage you wonder
why it always turns out that the people
at the world economic forum their
brother or their cousin or their wife or
whatever ends up working at the new york
times or at washington post or at forbes
or business insider it's all a big
circle jerk that's what it is people so
good work avi i like how what you just
you can't just ask that question we're
trying to have cappuccino we're just
trying to have a nice afternoon
cappuccino
the point of all of this is i feel this
was very therapeutic for me like i got a
lot of the crap that was going on this
week these were things that were just
sitting on us we couldn't fit them into
a show but that we were just waiting and
trust me it's just a small amount of the
stuff
that that just happens on each and every
week it's just man just wake up to it
and then once you see it you just see it
you sit with it
you go okay they're [ __ ] artists how
can i live my best life
that's what you got to do i really
believe it
so once again as i've said many times
you don't have to be a republican but
you cannot be a democrat
and you cannot be an elitist and you
cannot be someone who thinks you get to
control or all sorts of people because
if you're one of those people i don't
like you and we're not going to send you
a christmas card okay we're not going to
give you the drugs whatever it is that
he did before we're not going to give
you the implant chip okay guys join us
uh at rubinport.locals.com
uh if you want a live chat during the
show and part one of my interview with
nba star non-woke i should say non-woke
nba star my buddy jonathan isaac is up
right now on youtube the full thing is
up on locals and here's a little more of
the elderly gentleman pretending to be
president see you tomorrow hot i got a
lot of i got hairy legs that turn that
that that that that that turn uh um
blonde in the sun
and the kids used to come up and reach
in the pool and rub my leg down
so it was straight and then watch the
hair
come back up again
if you want to protect yourself get a
double barrel shotgun
have the shells a 12 gauge shotgun
don't jump
don't jump don't jump they look at it so
i learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap to
say that lgbtqt people have no
civil rights no man has a right to raise
a hand to a woman in anger we have to
just change the culture period and keep
punching at it and punching at it and
punching it it will be a big no i really
mean it
and immediately changed the law in the
state of delaware protecting transgender
people